de lo que quiero hablar en este vídeo es
de la noción de medida del arco muy bien
medida del arco y esto se refiere a
cuando estamos hablando de círculos muy
bien y como veremos cuando digamos
cuando cuando vemos el concepto de
medida del arco en realidad uno podría
pensar al inicio que es la longitud de
un arco de hecho lo voy a escribir por
acá para diferenciarlo verdad también
podríamos pensar en la longitud del arco
verdad y en realidad son ideas distintas
y por ello vamos a digamos vamos a
compararlas en este vídeo así que la
medida de un arco en realidad solo es
una forma elegante para llamarle digamos
a lo siguiente déjenme déjenme pintar un
círculo o al menos tratar de hacer una
especie de círculo que íbamos a hacer
aquí un círculo más o menos ahí tenemos
un círculo muy bien ahí tenemos un
círculo
y vamos a hacer la distinción de algunos
puntos por ejemplo vamos a pensar en el
punto central verdad el centro de este
círculo y vamos a llamarle o y vamos a
poner algunos puntos en la
circunferencia digamos vamos a poner
este punto y vamos a poner este punto b
y vamos a poner este punto ce que están
en la circunferencia y ahora vamos a
pensar en un ángulo particular vamos a
pensar en una en un ángulo central vamos
a pensar en este ángulo el ángulo b o a
este ángulo veo a digamos que este
ángulo mide 120 grados muy bien entonces
alguien a lo mejor puede llegar y
preguntarnos bueno cuál es la medida de
este arco ave muy bien entonces voy a
escribirlo así la medida puede ser que
alguien nos esté preguntando por la
medida del arco ave y este es digamos la
forma en la que representamos el
de verdad en realidad se refiere al arco
más chico porque por ejemplo para ir de
ave a lo largo de esta circunferencia
podríamos hacerlo de dos formas
podríamos ocupar este arco que es
digamos el más chico esta trayectoria
que es la más chica o podríamos ir en el
sentido inverso verdad que sería como la
forma más larga de llegar del punto a al
punto b sobre la circunferencia pero si
nos referimos digamos al largo a la
trayectoria larga en realidad tendríamos
que decir el arco acb bien tendríamos
que incluir un punto intermedio en este
caso como sólo estamos poniendo la letra
ay la letra b estamos refiriéndonos al
arco ave entonces en realidad debemos
pensar en el en el arco más corto muy
bien entonces si uno se pregunta cuál es
la medida del arco ave en realidad esto
es muy fácil esto es igual a la medida
del ángulo central que intersecta dicho
ha dicho dicho arco muy bien entonces en
este caso aquí tenemos este ángulo
central es de 120 grados e ínter seca al
arco a de entonces es la medida del arco
ave será igual a 120 voy a ponerlo bien
120 grados muy bien entonces qué pasaría
si nosotros pensamos ahora por ejemplo
en este otro arco digamos vamos a
recorrer de a a d pero en la otra
dirección entonces en realidad nos
estamos preguntando por la medida del
arco acb tenemos que escribir tres
puntos para referirnos al arco digamos
más largo verdad y si uno observa muy
bien si uno piensa por ejemplo entonces
en este ángulo central verdad este
ángulo azul sumado con este ángulo
amarillo de 120 grados debe ser en total
360 grados verdad entonces en realidad
este ángulo azul será 360 menos
20 y esto es igual a 240 grados verdad
entonces la medida del arco acb es igual
a la medida del ángulo central que
intersecta a este arco verdad entonces
esto será igual a 240 grados entonces
algo que podemos notar es que la medida
del arco en realidad es independiente
del tamaño del círculo verdad esto no
depende de qué tan grande o chico es el
círculo y eso es digamos la gran
diferencia entre lo que es la medida del
arco y la longitud del arco entonces de
hecho podemos tener dos círculos por
ejemplo de distinto tamaño pensemos nos
x hacen en este círculo chiquito verdad
y digamos que tenemos un ángulo central
aquí que tiene digamos que intersecta
cierto arco y digamos que tenemos un
círculo un poco más grande pero que
tiene la misma medida en el ángulo
central
y es justo el que intersecta a cierto
arco así que si pensamos que los ángulos
los ángulos centrales son iguales
entonces en realidad las medidas de los
dos arcos correspondientes son iguales
sin embargo las longitudes de los arcos
son distintos y también depende por
ejemplo del tamaño del círculo y de ahí
digamos que la medida del arco utiliza
digamos grados mientras que la longitud
de arco utiliza unidades de longitud
como podrían ser centímetros o metros
entonces vamos a escribir esto la medida
del arco es
a medida del ángulo
la medida del ángulo central verdad es
la medida del ángulo central que
intersecta al arco verdad que que
intersecta
al arco
arco muy bien y si nosotros pensamos por
ejemplo en la longitud del arco entonces
tendríamos que también pensar o agregar
digamos el tamaño del círculo tendríamos
que considerar el tamaño del círculo